When my sister texted me where I wanted to go for dinner,
I remembered that I'd never been to Din Tai Fung,
so that's exactly where she took me.
After an hour wait, we sat down and filled out a little order cards.
After she made us our little sauce concoctions,
brought out the garlic green beans,
the pork soup dumplings, and the cucumber salad.
This cucumber salad was so good
and probably my favorite thing that we ordered.
And even though Piper was raving about these soup dumplings,
I found them quite underwhelming,
to be honest. They weren't that hot,
and they were just lacking flavor.
But I really enjoyed the green beans.
And these stir fried rice cakes were so good,
which I haven't heard people talk about these ones.
We got the pork noodle, and I'm not even gonna talk about it
because it wasn't worth talking about.
I also got the honey lemonade with some Boba in it,
which I found quite good. We're skipping over the mushroom fried rice.
I didn't realize how much food we ordered until it all came out.
The spicy noodles and spicy wontons were so fragrant.
Not too spicy. I was bursting at the seams,
but needed something sweet.
So we got the chocolate dumplings with sea salt foam.
These weren't my favorite,
but I was so tired and the restaurant was closing, so we headed home.